per adesso i benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono pani leo ci sono orgoglioso
di presentarvi uomo che si mette le
cuffie sotto le altre cuffie prove a
parte quello il gioco di pokémon per
eccellenza stiamo parlando di pokemon
spada perché io sono ottimista da non
timi scudo però sono giocabili sia su
nintendo switch che su nintendo switch
lai come vi avevo detto in un video
circa un mesetto fa più o meno io
l'avevo già provato a londra sono tra
l'altro a provarlo quindi avevo già
giocato la prima parte è oggi volevo
riprendere più o meno dal punto in cui
avevo lasciato quindi non vedrete il mio
gameplay di spada dall'inizio inizio
ragazzi è finalmente arrivato il momento
di addentrarci tutti insieme nel
nuovissimo gioco di pokemon per nintendo
switch allora siamo nella mitica regione
di gala galan che sarebbe tipo una
location londinese cenno in inghilterra
e inglese a quanto pare i dettagli del
nuovo che non sono devastanti spiegato
perché ho giocato scarpata vicino più
che altro perché avevo già giocato
all'esito pikachu è let's go id e quindi
magica a posto volevo questo aiutato la
pokémon ragazzi io non non so quanto
quanti pokemon riuscire a catturare in
questo video anche perché diciamo che
nel mio stile di gioco di pokémon io
cerco sempre di catturarli
all'inizio e poi a lungo andare aprendo
solo i più forti perché dentro di
allenarmi ii e magica è uno di questi
perché voglio assolutamente gary dott
detto questo nel pokédex appunto non si
sta per aprire quest'anno ci sono sia
pokemon nuovi di nuova generazione sia
pokemon vecchi quindi del vecchio
pokédex tra i quali anche
magica dove l'evoluzione il mio
preferito non come magica perché magica
non combina niente un po come nella vita
comunque sì e non se lo si fosse capito
i pokémon sono visibili come lo erano
anche le scopi e poi grande rispetto
agli altri pokémon ringraziando iddio
non devi più utilizzare condividi
esperienza per far salire i pokemon
quelli scarsi perché l'esperienza la
prendono tutti i manuali finale paese
luigia steaming con la città del vapore
quindi abbiamo abbiamo preso il treno
forza seguimi bavena programma torna c'è
una torre in fondo ruo incredibile
bellissimo mi piace molto di più la
torre dietro comunque con la laggiù e
steve intonava arrivarci a piedi che
siamo dei pigri arrivarci col treno
ragazzi che si sono le terre selvagge la
gente che pesca cucciolo knicks perché
avete un oggetto qua ciao a knicks posso
catturarti io ho trovato un messaggio di
pokemon di grandi dimensioni che si
incontrano per del selvaggio sono
davvero forti prova da affrontare ma se
ti sembra di non farcela fugge mi
raccomando fuggi ma che cosa pensi di me
pensi che io faccia schifo vieni qua
onyx non mi fai paura
il mio io lo scor vania 10 quanto ti per
come ti permetti di affrontarmi anzi è
la prima volta che in un gioco di
pokémon vedo incontro un po che non
all'inizio che così alto di livello se
lo catturò 1 nizza al 26
all'inizio è incredibile ma non posso
lanciare il poker come tentativo di fuga
fallito magari aiuto ma dov è lasciato
con bandi ma cosa nuova pre aiuto ma
stavo scherzando manda in campo
l'aspetto c'è la fuga non ce la fa
magica rpa i fatti lo fai vedere chi sei
mamma mia come la vinciamo questa
partita è madonna
se non vinciamo noi guarda perché sono
fuggito magi carpe salvo niente se
uscite va bene
un centro pokémon in questo momento non
mi farebbe male però qui in cul
o mio dio da pokemon rubino i raid
dynamax se riesce a sconfiggere un
pokémon dynamax avrà l'opportunità che
di catturarlo lo so evocando dynamax
sono incredibilmente forti e reagiscono
in modo particolare ad esempio sferrando
raffiche di mosse e importante che tutti
e quattro gli allevatori coinvolti
collaborino per sconfiggere i ragazzi io
non potrò mai battere un pokémon dynamax
però proviamoci
ma veramente stiamo provando questa cosa
ti rendi conto che ci sono riuscito a
farmi battere da un onyx va bene ciao
top
sappi che non ti basterà mai vice
corbani mi sembri proprio della taglia
giusta per battere un dynamax ragazzi
non ce la farò mai a battere un pokémon
dynamax c'è almeno non adesso posso
usare il mio dynamax daina fiammata suo
top vai dynamax aties corbani prima sono
stato spedito da noli quindi non so
quanto voi la madonna ci fai palestra
questa può che con l'elezione o uno
score vanni che è un gigante a posto
sono ritornato full ps fratello mio non
sai contro chi ti stai mettendo in
acustiche
quello è morto ma come mi dico va bene
lo scorfano i loro zaina fiammata vai
grande l'abbiamo battuto non ce la
faremo mai ragazzi vai vai ragazzi vai
corpo scontro bravi voglio questo 88 e
lo voglio subito ex ragazzi renderli
potete fare anche online e teoricamente
quando sto facendo in locale proprio da
una fiammata madonna è un'eruzione
vulcanica quasi andato no no no no non è
adesso non l'ho visto ma adesso ti prego
ti prego fallo fuori subito no azione ho
sbagliato a vero fair attacco rapido
bravo bravo ce l'abbiamo
abbiamo fatto fuori un pokémon dynamax
incredibile nel momento giusto per
lasciare a poche ball by law sfera gli
una poké ball ceo catturato sostengono
voglio dire non dire 88 e se non ce
l'hai nel sacco sempre di più
perché prima trovata la cella un onyx
mandato
avuto successo quindi proviamoci ti
prego di ventri ding ding 2
veramente è riuscita a catturare un
dynamax e non ci posso credere ma come
come ho fatto grave la rara ma dato una
caramella rara ma veramente non ragazzi
incredibile catturato pokemon dynamax
sul serio a livello 20 ott otto diventa
locke tower e poi diventa clock tower
fighissimo inserito la caramella rare al
20 teoricamente dovrebbe evolversi
vediamo un attimo ragazzi se riesco a
far evolvere subito un po abbiamo tutti
sto visto video per cortesia o top
mettevo invitiamo il video il video al
video vedete voi dite voi dite orbiti se
al 20
signori proprio lui lo trova dynamax e
lo fa evolvere
ho trovato un nuovo pokemon principale
north tower dynamite scure grazie grazie
a tutti
troppi applausi grazie mille da what's
hot scarsi il mio è un no tav come si
pronunciano town cosa diavolo è quella
roba lì ma è la cosa più tenera che io
abbia mai visto un aiuto cos'è cos'è
cos'è successo
nove ragazzi scusate non l'ha scagliata
ti affronto ma perché voglio capire chi
sei
[Applauso]
incredibile
be where corso mischiato la parola
vestire quindi orso vestito tipo va bene
e al 34 corsa due cose ma ora che è
impossibile non lo farò mai
al 30 quando de fuga no no no no no no
no no no ti prego esci pasta è sì fuga
via come la madonna bellissimo siamo ha
sfinito
c'è un onyx che lo stesso di prima aveva
fatto un mazzo così che fico che ci sono
i negozi a lato madonna quanto veramente
un pokémon incredibile non a parte gli
scherzi su perfezione
ok
[Musica]
comunque è disseminato di oggetti non ho
capito se come i pokemon vecchi anche se
tiri una manata anche se cerchi un
oggetto nascosti simo magari lo trovi lo
stesso anche se non brilla
oppure se devono per forza brillare sono
non c'è niente questa evidente le piante
non mi serve zard lancia lizard e
charitate dico di del fratello del mio
rivale come si chiama dan del mi ero
dimenticato ciò dan del caro il mio
ciari già ben se non ci fossi tu non
riuscire neanche ad arrivare allo stadio
mazza non potrei nemmeno questo enorme
ascensore no quello si chiama avere
problemi di vista metti degli occhiali
zio vado di sopra del corsera ma tocca
ascensori credibile lo voglio anch'io
bellissima che idea assurda ma potrà
farlo dritto che salivano spero che
questo video vi sia piaciuto
io sono sempre orgoglioso di portarvi i
nuovi pokémon quando escono melo finirà
tutto in due giorni non va bene spero di
no perché almeno me lo godo un po di più
però sapete di pokémon più forti dei
miei non è vero mentita voi stessi
vorrei potervi spoilerare le città
gigantesche che esistono il project
sword oppure in poche noi c è all
oppure c'è anche sono anche percorsi
innevati che però se io li dovessi fare
davvero una vita reale dovrei usare il
po che campeggiano i quattro secondi
perché io con 25 gradi c o freddo quindi
lasciate un commento qui sotto ragazzi
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciate il
tasto mi piace perché merita tutto
subito con uno spalto fatemi eccola
fatemi sapere che altri sette team scudo
ti spada perché so che mi prendevo che
uno scudo a delle diversità rispetto a
spada ci sia tipo la versione arcobaleno
sa di pony tra mi pare non voglio dire
una cavolata però una delle delle cose
oltre al leggendario che cambiano
scegliamo prossimo video io ringrazio
anche nintendo per aver sponsorizzato
questo video è però è rifatto andare a
londra anche un mese fa per aver provato
poche ma come sempre ci diamo hanno
proseguito bella ragazza
non credo esista giornata migliore di
questa per registrare il gameplay
fortunatamente macché
[Musica]
ma tutto a posto
fai tu va bene e niente
vabbè se si diverte
[Musica]